we talked about this film earlier in the
week with Nick Swardson who accused this
man of being so adverse to to jogging
that he insisted they do a fast walk
during a take of this film that the
director stopped in the middle so
there's some controversy on the set
right Chris there's some controversy for
sure and you know this man because the
mother of your child Sarah Tiana
has done much producing writing
reporting for this man's work
indeed the star of the wrong Missy on
Netflix our friend David Spade back here
how are you David
[Music]
it's my wait what about this yes Richard
what's that from my fourth grade teacher
saying where's your homework no it's
from Tommy Boy when he goes Richard aid
no no it's deep one that's a deep one
but playable that's good deep cuts it's
not even real but you know I read buddy
how are you David Spade how are you
I like that that little pork pie sorts
it was making fun of me well he said
that a scene in the wrong Missy called
for you to jog around a pool you said to
him before action was called let's do a
slow let's do it fast
director bass is a true story yeah I
don't come off the blocks like I used to
okay I make more money doing funny
movement I don't really an eye roll yeah
we were doing it and I got a bad neck
and I realized I don't even run anymore
and and they go you split around the
corner and first first and more
realistically I go listen I'm not doing
50 takes of sprinting alright let's
let's keep this thing within reason so
let's do this not even a slow jog I
started with slow jog and I downgraded
to a fast walk and he goes dude we're
running that's the idea and I go I know
but just I had to make it make sense
actually I go well because everyone's
looking
and I think something's wrong you know
the character so we have to be like
we're in a big hurry we're just gonna go
across campus here and he just rolled
his eyes I was like Nick come on Matt
play along no one's looking at this
movie for realism
I thought something on Twitter and
they're like this Ragna trending and the
critics are split I'm like yes that
means somebody liked it so you don't
mind the split critics that means
because you know listen I love the movie
and there's that's number one right
that's great but but you know that the
critics are never like going out of
their way to say how great these movies
are I like it so one day you wake up
you're like if all the tomatoes are not
rotten I'm in good shape right that's
pretty much it that's what you're right
I think the best Tomatoes I got yes baby
on the do-over and I think it was nine
gonna keep me out of the all-star game
Jack and Jill we got - - I don't know
grown-ups I do have at least a 90
Tomatoes I mean I gotta have a lot of
tomatoes for grown-ups
we can go on and on about it right that
was the first time I've been in a movie
do well number one is different on
Netflix gonna meet real world of the
world but grown-ups was last one and now
is probably never going to do is no one
yeah no you know I don't know works out
there you know I'll take whatever I can
get David Spade Netflix is the wrong
Missy check it out on Netflix right now
so you seen a preview that I look like
Bob Costas for some reason so um I have
seen a preview of it David yeah the
Costas thing didn't come to mind though
what makes you look called custodian you
think pistachio I dyed my hair dark
brown and I gave myself little bangs and
I didn't mean to but I look a little
like Bob Odenkirk and better call Saul
and I look a little like Costas and I
look a little bit like myself as a
doofus I also show
which I'm terrified of yes that is that
is bats jarring that's a little jarring
people don't get out jarring is then
they do they see me they go thank you
they go you need to look 20 or 90 I go I
know I'm that's one second but I had a
girl on school I am that stupid mustache
I go do you think I wanted I look worse
without it if you can imagine she is
there's no way you can look any worse
they go oh yes there is the night shirt
clips in the wrong Missy she's like Oh
fantastic Oh ma'am I wonder what I'll
want to ask you there's just so much to
ask you about so many things there are
because I don't know I I don't think
I've ever really delved into your Tommy
Boy black sheep era type stuff with you
I saw the UFC fight at the sports thing
all right what do you what did you think
of that I felt bad for Ferguson because
he was supposed to fight khabib right
well yeah I just you know he couldn't
compete well net I guess it could have
helped him it he didn't fight me well I
mean I think Ferguson might have been
off his game that night I mean might
have been but you know he probably had a
bad day because he just could not get it
going and I felt that he's supposed to
fight to be banned like some huge you
know arena with thousands of people
instead he's like in some Jacksonville
Outback Steakhouse parking lot you know
kiddy corner to Applebee's with six
people at there and he loses how I
pictured it walked away looking like
Gollum with a hangover I'm like oh boy I
think you should see the other guy like
no we should see you Gollum with a
hangover it's a great that is that is
one I did not think of is that your
friend is that your new fantasy team
nickname Chris pretty good one that's
pretty good one to put down here hold on
we're at this so Chris do you want to
did you guys send a thank-you note to
David yet for the baby gift for you and
Sarah yeah well could this could suffice
as down no I have to write one thank you
Dave
I'm not gonna say that I was in charge
of any of the announcements or thank-you
notes
you know Sarah took care of all
so you should have what did I give you a
lights-out hat or something yeah a
lights-out had a portable battery pack
and I stole that from the green room but
goodie from Jimmy Kimmel did you really
steal something from the lights on it
was a gift pack that they give the
panelists yeah but you're not rich yeah
you go in there and you didn't you rifle
through the dressing room and then
suddenly jo koy wonders where is you
know well you know it's interesting
though David you know what you've done
in our green room you signed the wall
next to a a signature filled I guess
poster from one of our Super Bowls you
sign the wall in our Grimm's green room
saying can I sign here David Spade you
know there's no no there's no one else
on the wall David you're the only one
you did ask but in the signature you
know like it wasn't I guess it was the
forgiveness rather than permission
moment right there I by the way I've
good news yes if people are listening I
don't know if this airs outside of LA
but yes it does nyet
okay good the governor said we're on
phase one of opening up California which
is great so as of today all archery
repair stores are open the caterpillar
sanctuaries great rock quarries Rock or
less I'm like where does it kick into my
life what's happening here tree cleaners
well I don't know if this is helping me
Wednesday's - they're like oh just
number well I mean it could be in time
for for for your do your fantasy
football draft David you got it you got
my wits to prepare now you got weeks to
prepare you have no excuse coming up
this fall I've only I've only done 3,000
mock drafts that's what everyone does do
you know mocked up I'm like already I
gotta get in the game man
got to otherwise you're gonna get lost
you'll get absolutely hi Marie my guy
that's right the DeAndre Hopkins is now
gonna be on a team David that's a that's
impressive I know by than yelling at my
assistant because she's louder than me
yeah they said who that was I honestly
thought you were in an airport and I'm
like what does that go what if the hell
is going on in the background there that
is amazing they're doing you know I have
to do the Kelly Ripa on Monday and they
so they have to zoom you ahead of time
and then they're like we need to know
that you have a really big house we need
to see it and we need to talk to her
people it's like oh I thought me and you
were zooming and I set it all up I look
super cool I got everything set up my
house looks like I'm rich I had a little
money bag behind me and then and they go
no it's just call and I go what I'm
sorry you went through all that trouble
to put your money bag where and where it
needs to be seen you know it's funny in
in the sports world David all of us when
we're zooming we're sitting in front of
bookshelves we've chosen all sports
people have chosen bookshelves
you know what I mean like we're there
I'm sitting in front of a bookshelf I
literally have not touched those books
since I moved in to my house probably
about two and a half years ago I just
painted there I know I I know it's a
little snoozy but I guess it makes
people feel professional or smart or
something I want to see a scientist in
front of a bookshelf or maybe a
microscope on their desk and like oh
this one means business you know I mean
do you have a book how do you have a
bookshelf in your house I think the
question is do I have a book I think I
have one or two books and they're both
mine well I've seen your monologues on
your Instagram feed David I mean you
know you I think I might have spotted a
book out there other great are you
kidding me
they're phenomenal you like it I didn't
say like to all of them
yeah they are thank you I do jokes in
the morning and little affero send
there's a joke she's great she's era
tiana is great
Chris yeah Chris I mean you're you know
household is is filled with laughter and
a crazy baby named cage cage yep cage
it's pretty cool I mean I know it's a
little rough slide there for a second
one's gonna settle in but I like Kate I
think it's a good name what is that what
does that mean two days it would be
appeared on lights out is that right
that's his first time its first
appearance the only two day old to be in
a union you don't want a name like Dave
my name is so Marlon blando Dave is like
the dumbest thing I I should I would
sound younger by changing the Conner or
something Ellen be like hey Conner
spayed I'm like yeah it's never too late
David all right the wrong Missy
available now on Netflix
it is number one half the critics love
it see I went glass half full no there's
an actual Gulf skins game tournament
that's going down this weekend and I've
got Brandel Chamblee of the Golf Channel
that's coming up that's what I got
alright my pen out to take notes Thank
You Davey on this bike thanks to you the
best brothers my big closer okay let's
zoom it you bet David Spade Netflix is
the wrong Missy hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here